[музика]
якщо вже воювати то воювати в
боєздатному підрозділі в підготовленому
війську Наша задача проштурмувати тобто
забрати ці окопи у ворога зайняти їх
тебе везуть ти
сидиш і все і ти нічого не можеш зробити
оце дуже страшно вже навіть
бійці Америки визназна те що вони
вчаться вже у нас тобто не ми у
них ти там находишся ти твориш історію і
ти ну якійсь мірі ти записуєш себе в
історію Ну а після штурму Коли ти
повертаєшся перше що ти думаєш що ти
живий клас все Живи і слава
богу якщо вже воювати то воювати в
боєздатному підрозділі в підготовленому
війську Тобто цечим ми відрізняємось це
високим рівнем підготовки і Ну як навіть
багато військових визнають що третя
штурмова набула статусу елітної елітної
бригади Ну і хотілось воюватись кращими
просто плічво пліч я розумів що в таких
в більш активних контактних підрозділах
ну медиків не вистачає я знаходжусь з
групою але ну оскільки я медик я трошки
позаду від групи від осно від Ударної
скажемо так але так я разом з ними
постійно і в разі необхідності я можу
занімати абсолютно
любу позицію
раніше мій рюкзак Був менший тому що ну
була така мобільна робота це був
постійно
медивак поруч тобто я працював і як на
виході так і на медиваку і я знав що
медивак - це машина медична вона десь не
неподалік і ну а в цій машині відповідно
все що треба для допомоги є Тому це був
невеличкий
рюкзачок щоб ну скажемо так на Колінці
швиденько підлатати зараз доводиться з
собою навіть інфузії носити інфузія ну
тобто розчини для капання бійців Тому що
інколи евакуація досить складний процес
не завжди може транспорт їхати і забрати
важко поранених
Ми можемо сидіти В окопах але це
короткий проміжок часу тому що ми
штурмовий підрозділ Наша задача
проштурмувати тобто забрати ці окопи у
ворога зайняти їх і потім Так ми
закріплюємось в межах нашого нашої
бригади у нас є і артилерія і арозвідка
і різні типи озброєння які дуже часто
просто ну прикривають нас
тобто так само аеророзвідка вона нам
допомагає дізнатись що перед нами навіть
коли ми штурмуємо на ми знаходимось на
полі бою і ми на здавалося б бачимо все
але коли над нами висить наш Дрон він
бачить вперед там на 100-200 м і він
може нас попереджати чи підтягуються
якісь
резерви що там відбувається чи вони
навпаки відступають перший штурм - це
невідомість ти їдеш в якусь невідомість
так там тренування були до
цього хлопці досвідчені там діляться
досвідом розказують що як відбувається
ти
дивишся Відео зі штурмів як це
відбувається Ну плюс саме підготовка там
література І все тому подібне але все
одно ти їдеш Ти цього раніше не пробував
ти цього раніше не робив невідомість
плюс нас якраз в мій перший штурм дуже
прекрасно
зустрічали мінометним вогнм протягом 14
годин ну
і було страшно Десь весело Десь не дуже
Ну але перший штурм
пройшов ти зрозумів в принципі
що можна жить можна жить можна працювать
Ну і а далі вже
понакатаній ми вчимся абсолютно всьому І
абсолютно ну абсолютно в всьому і
постійно тобто якщо ми не Вою якщо нас
там відпочинок якийсь У нас постійно
йдуть тренування ці тренування
направлені як на фізичні можливості
Тобто це
фіспідготовка так це і полігони тактика
тактична медицина
топографія радіозв'язок тобто абсолютно
все тренуємо абсолютно все вчимо
і ну це цікавіше ти
знаєш на що ти може може
розраховувати під час екстрених
ситуацій на що ти можеш розраховувати в
плані реакції
своєї тому що Ну у нас тренування
максимально наближені до бойових дій Ти
вже просто коли знаходишся ну скажемо
так на на полі бою твої інстинкти
падають до рівня твоїх твоїх знань ти
просто робиш все на автоматі у мене
страх Ну як мабуть у більшості моїх
побра ну тобто
піхотинців це страх заходу на позицію
тобто коли ти ще їдеш в транспорті і От
ця невідомість коли ти їдеш в транспорті
коли ти не бачиш що навколо відбувається
АА і коли від тебе нічого не залежить
тобто тебе везуть ти
сидиш і все і ти нічого не можеш зробити
оце дуже страшно а Коли вже ти приїхав
коли ти вигружаєшся з транспорту І коли
перед тобою там посадка ти вже знаєш що
тобі треба робити І тут
вже майже все залежить від того
наскільки ти
натренований тобто Да є фактор який
називається везіння Але знову ж таки цей
Фактор можна зменшити зменшити якщо ти
правильно дієш під час штурму ми
відрізняємось
від більшості військовослужбовців тому
що у нас майже все що можна обвішати
бронею ми обвішуємо бронею це починаючи
від ший і закінчуючи ногами Тобто це
горжети наплічники напашники напоперек
там броня коли ми заходимо противник
завжди знає що ми заходимо і він ніколи
не шкодує на нас БК Тобто це постійно
мінометний артобстріл обстріл загсів і в
досить великій кількості І тому Ну
можливо ми і не хотіли б стільки броні
але ми просто вимушені носити тому що що
Осколки постійно літають десь біля нас
загалом повністю вся екіпіровка плюс
додаткове БК І в залежності від
спеціалізації хто гранатометник хто
медник хто кулеметник вся екіпіровка
може важити до 50 кг і інколи це можуть
бути марші там по 5-8 км і це добре якщо
це марші по прямій по дорозі по якійсь А
якщо це по розбитій посадці то
а просто не витримують Деякі хлопці які
от недостатньо треновані про стандарти
НАТО тут мабуть вже можна ска ну це вже
перечому не мої здогадки а побратими
спілкуються з бійцями НАТО а конкретно з
марпєхами і з піхотинцями американцями і
вже навіть
бійці Америки визнають те що вони
вчаться вже у нас ми використовуємо як
натівські підходи до війни так
з радянської школи теж можна взяти якісь
окремі уроки Так це вже і на власному
досвіді якісь стратегії якісь тактики
вироблені Тому це все змішується
міксується плюс досвід наших
командирів як відомо наші майже всі наші
командири це вихідці Азову вони про
завдяки їм і живе ідейність Азову
вони підтримують наші бойові навички я
брав участь під андріївкою Тобто це
підходи до Андріївки андріївку бої були
важкі ну там було дуже важко дуже велика
концентрація ворога була але ворог
виявився не такий мотивований не такий
підготований як ми ну це для цивільних
відповідь 72 мотобригада
їхня штормз їхні
підрозділ тюремщиків яких набрали просто
як ну просто як м'ясо
а були ще якісь підрозділи десантних
військ Наскільки я
знаю один раз навіть під час наших ну
мого виходу один раз навіть ахмат сила
приїхала правда
ненадовго росіяни добре
копають для для оборони їхнього їхні
бліндажі дуже прекрасно підходять
ховатись в них можна перечікувати
обстріли в них
можна Ну так щоб жити ну мабуть ні Ну
тому що це такі це проміжкові
а точки Ну і проміжкові позиції під час
штурмів
це не якась там лінія оборони коли йде
активний штурм ну викопуються позиції
там на на скору руку скажемо так просто
щоб було де пересидіти коли ти
звикаєш ну умовно кажучи до посадки і до
того що відбувається в посадці і Коли ти
повертаєшся в цивільне
життя є певний ступор є певна
розсіяність якась чи як це правильно
назвати ну тобто
так відчувається
а різниця
в
цінностях Мабуть так можна це назвати Я
б не сказав би що Це
гнів якесь відчуття певне
несправедливості так воно є
але війна йде так Але ж це не означає що
людям треба закритись там в підвалі і
чекати люди мають Там право на
відпочинок на ще щось але ну просто це
особисте відчуття
несправедливості А так ну злості
негативу якогось абсолютно немає наш
підрозділ підрозділ націоналістів Ми
вмотивовані мабуть Ну не знаю Більше не
більше за всіх але ми вмотивовані
і штурм скажемо так
це для нас яко якогось роду визнання
Тобто ти там находишся ти твориш історію
і ти ну в якійсь мірі ти записуєш себе в
історію Ну а після штурму коли ти
повертаєшся перше що ти думаєш що ти
живий клас все живий слава
[музика]
Богу